first of all the guy everyone's talking
about these days of course Donald Trump
and now you're on the show tonight and I
have to ask you
you've known Trump you've worked with
Donald Trump on Celebrity Apprentice so
you know this guy well what are your
thoughts on the guy having worked with
him I think we'd like to know okay
working with him he was an absolute
gentleman very respectful very nice
mm-hmm
so I cannot put him down as a person but
he just seems to think like when you
watch him on the debates it just reminds
me of a three-hour episode of The
Apprentice that's what it's like right
exactly the same way the same way the
wives cracks the one-liners they're
beautiful it's like oh you don't mean to
act that way right serious come on get
in there about you do you think he's not
serious about it like everyone says he's
serious he says he's serious but I have
this opinion sometimes when I'm watching
him like no no this is like to help sell
Trump steaks or something like listen
see the brand thing is he's rolling the
dice if by some chance he does make it
fantastic if he doesn't he's built his
empire even bigger even bigger worldwide
everybody knows that name you know so he
can't lose really right right so you
like it was a person what do you think
if he did become president would you be
would you be fine with that I would be
terrified because he's a narcissist I
mean he just is he knows that about
himself you know and he doesn't take
comment well and if anybody disagrees
with him he doesn't take it well and to
think that this man would have his hand
on that button right oh can you imagine
yeah I mean he's got such a quick fiery
temper it's like oh no way yeah no he
could never be in a big ocean delusion
[Music]
[Applause]
he just doesn't seem to have controlled
that that temper or that initial
reaction you know with the wisecracking
it's like I get the vibe I keep getting
from I'm sure many people have made this
point but I get mussolini from him he
stands it there he he's got that kind of
like these nodding I should give him
some of my my medals he hates to wear
medals yesterday you know I'm sure he'll
create his own medal collection with
ribbons to start wearing yeah right in
putting mouths on other people you
you're the Trump ears Trump I've ever
seen